- All right!
Now, it's time to bring a
little extra joys to your day.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
So last season we met a woman named Lisa,
who wanted to cheer up some
kids in her neighborhood.
So she conjured up a
fantastical world filled
with fairies where children
could engage and adults
if you're into that kind
of thing, it was a hit.
I love it.
It was a hit and the kids
started writing letters
to the fairies and getting responses.
Let's take a look back right now.
- It really began during the lockdown.
I met these two little girls
one right after the other
and they were so miserable.
That I decided to teach
them about the fairies.
And I told them that the
fairies had come back
to our realm to help them
find their happy thoughts
and that they should bring them cake.
And then one of the little girls came back
to my door and knocked on the door
and asked if the fairies
lived in my garden.
And I told them
that what we really needed to
do was make a space for them
and we would get a door and
the fairies would come through.
And Amazon came through
and so did the door.
And then the fairies magically appeared
and started writing to the children.
(audience cheering)
- No joke,
after this show I literally
built a whole fair garden
in my backyard with my children.
No joke.
We were really into it.
Since then the fairies
have found a second home.
Usually we do this segment
virtually, but come on
I could not resist the opportunity
to meet another former guest
in real life and fairy lover.
So Lisa is here to share the update,
give it up from Lisa y'all.
(audience cheering)
- So what's the latest with the fairies?
- Well, I dunno if you've
ever heard of a witness tree.
- [Kelly] No.
- But the fairies were a
witness to the pandemic.
And so they're being honored
and they're being put into
the Library of Congress
for being a witness to the
trials that people went
through a help and now
a historic landmark.
- [Kelly] Aww.
Which means that the "Kelly Clarkson Show"
or maybe I should call it
the "Fairy Clarkson Show".
- I'm into that one.
- Yes.
- Is going to be immortalized in the
Library of Congress as part
of American history for the pandemic.
- Oh my gosh.
That's so cool.
- So, but fairies still live
in your neighborhood right?
- Well of course they do.
- They live in mine too,
they're in our backyard.
- Well, they're not going
anywhere anytime soon.
But the good news is that children
are doing much better emotionally now
than they were this time last year.
But what we did find out is
that when everybody went back
from virtual to being in person
all of their bullies
came in, in person too.
So, so many kids are
coping with that right now
that that is like the top
priority for the fairies.
- Yeah. Thank you so much, Lisa.
Thank I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all our season
long partner Pilot Pin,
the go pin of the "Kelly
Clarkson Show" thinks
what you're doing is so important.
So in recognition
they'd like to use their G2
Gelling Pen to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
- Wow.
- Yes!
You can do a lot of cool stuff
for the fairies with that.